hi i'm paul rudd and i want to share
with you this exclusive clip from
ant-man and the wasp so if we had an old
suit we might be able to track down the
lab yes but we don't what if we did what
do you mean I mean life's funny oh my
god
you didn't destroy the suit what well it
was your life's work Hank I couldn't
destroy that before I turn myself in I
shrunk it down and mailed it to Louise
you sent my suit for the mayor hey the
postal service is very reliable you know
they do tracking numbers now like UPS
where is it that's in a very safe place
all right don't worry what the trophy oh
it's not here what you mean it's not
there where could you be
I looked everyone's out here hey get
away from the playback after Cassie and
I would Chantel Scotty well the good
news is I know where it is
whenever you go back to school isn't
everything supposed to look so much
smaller this place seems huge a new
regulator Hank what's going on with this
suit how much of a work in progress is
this what are you laughing come please
okay what do you see the sizing coils
are malfunctioning
just let me sorry awesome
if only kappa see you now hilarious what
are we gonna do
[Music]
hey where's your Hall Pass hey I'm
talking to you
[Music]
you can do it got it
[Music]
don't peanut
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]
hiya champ how was school today haha
alright get your jokes out now can you
fix the suit some cranky you want a
juice box and some string cheese do you
really have it
[Music]
[Applause]
you